so when you look down at that then
that's like an X it is one of my X
favorite numbers for a while my favorite
number was three thousand four hundred
and thirty five and I save for a while
because I don't think of favorite
numbers you know commit to a favorite
number for life to be honest very few
things don't have a static opinion on
what is my favorite other than my
girlfriend
whereas three four three five for a
while there was was one of my top number
I show you why three four and actually
it probably had a bit of a record run as
being my favorite number three thousand
four and thirty five it's called the
Munchausen number and what you do for a
Munchausen number is you raise each of
the digits to the power of that digit so
3 to the 3 plus 4 to the 4 plus 3 to the
3 plus 5 to the 5 and if you then add 3
to the 3 plus 4 to the 4 plus 3 the 5 of
5 8 equals 3 4 3 5 it equals itself it's
a bit like a narcissistic number which
I'm sure people will be talking about
except this time each number is obsessed
with itself in fact it's mainly
munchausen that's named after was a
narcissistic character and so it's a
very very narcissistic number and what's
even better about it is it's the only
one in base 10 this is the only number
which has that property well well it was
the only number that has that property
if you look up online whenever you talk
about the Munchausen number and you
write you talk about 3 for 35 someone
will come along and see but what about
438 million five hundred and seventy
nine thousand and 88 huh what about that
because that to be your tongue wasn't it
because 4 to the 4 plus 3 to the 3 plus
8 to the 8 plus 5 to the 5 plus 7 to the
7 plus 9 to the 9 plus 0 to the 0 plus 8
to the 8 plus 8 to the 8 equals 4 3 8 5
7 9
zero eight eight and people are all up
in your grill with what up with this and
there is there is a problem with that
there's a reason why that makes me
emotional I'll show you why it is this
bit here zero to the zero this relies on
zero to the zero equaling zero and it
turns out zero to the zero does not
equal zero north of equal one for that
matter zero to the zero is undefined
there is no value for zero to the zero
because anything to the zero equals 1
and 0 to the anything equals zero and
when both of those things happen at once
you can you basically have a big
argument and people get very emotional
about this if you want to find our
equally core numbers there are things
like 4 1 5 5 which equals in the digits
at the bottom 4 1 5 5 ^ the same digits
but not necessarily in the same order so
if you put them up as in 5 4 1 5 that
still holds but you've got to shuffle
the digits around when you raise them up
the top you mentioned to me that was
your favorite number for a long time it
was your favorite number for possibly a
record oh it must have been seven or
eight months it was that feels good what
happened why why'd you break up oh it
was fun but it just it I got bored I got
bored and I went back to the safety of
narcissistic numbers for a while so 371
took over for a substantial period of
time and then I want to go back into
perfect numbers for a while so 33
million five hundred fifty thousand
three hundred and thirty-six
took back over and at the moment it's
seven hundred and sixty-four but that's
that's because it's a grafting number
but this is not the time nor the place
to talk about crafting homes